men go to war men clean sewers men clean
body parts off of
walls men um are
proctologists men give
colonoscopies um right they do all sorts
of
things and I know women do all those
things too okay but in this case we're
talking about your
husband the problem is not doing the job
it's not even the management of his
job I don't want to blame the job or his
boss for how he chooses to treat his
family and how he chooses to treat
himself now here's where that gets
really uncomfortable inside a home it's
actually I'm already uncomfortable I
know you know why because it's easier
for you you can sleep better at night
blaming his boss